Our first panelist is professor of linguistics
and Executive Director of the Center for Teaching
Research and Learning at American University.
Please welcome Naomi Baron.
Next is the Paulette Goddard chair of digital
media and learning sciences and a professor
in the Steinhardt School of Culture Education
and Human Development here at NYU. Please
welcome Jan Plass.
Also joining us is associate professor of
child and adolescent psychiatry at NYU School
of Medicine and clinical psychologist and
neuropsychologist at the Child Study Center
of the NYU Langone Medical Center. Please
welcome Dr. Richard Gallagher.
Last but not least we have a postdoctoral
fellow in the department of psychology at
Temple University. She's also a visiting associate
assistant professor at Haverford College.
Please welcome Lauren Sherman.
So we start with a couple of givens. We're
all social creatures as humans. And recent
research suggests that social interaction
in small and larger groups has media play
a key role in our evolution and survival and
fanning out across the planet. But that all
happened in a very different environmental
landscape. We know that in other cases take
the obesity epidemic in the United States
where we were evolved not to live in a land
of Coca-Cola and french fries. There's there's
consequences when the nature of the environment
around us change changes. And for sure that
that's happened with social interaction with
digital media and online platforms. So first
from each of you I'd love to hear what you
think the headline is about how social and
digital media are affecting young people in
particular as they grow up in the world today.
Let's start with you Naomi. You've done research
on how social media is affecting children
and teenagers reading and in other affects.
What's your biggest headline finding
The biggest finding, as far as I can tell
now, and I'm saying that because we really
don't have nearly enough research, is we assume
that reading digitally is no different from
reading in print. We don't know that for a
fact. My major concern is that the devices
on which we do our digital reading are devices
that were designed for very different kinds
of activity and we can call it interactive
activity sometimes socially interactive sometimes
interactive with sites but it's activity that
leads you to spend a very small amount of
time on it on a particular screen where it
leads you to multitask. It doesn't lead you
to sit back and concentrate which is what
in principle, not always in practice, but
in principle print allowed us to do.So my
major concern my headline is until we really
know how to train people to take the mindset
of reading in print and use that reading digitally
we're going to be incredibly shallow readers
and there's some studies that have been done
that can suggest that's what's happening.
Lauren you've studied the effects of social
media on the teenager and adult in real time.
Can you describe your really interesting experiments?
Yes so it was really surprising to me that
up until very recently nobody had actually
looked to see what's going on in the brain
when adolescents or really people of any age
were using social media. And so we have all
these questions. We want to know what are
the effects of social media. What are the
effects of technology on the brain and so
you think a very first step would just be
to say alright let's put someone in the MRI
scanner and let's see what's going on in their
brain when they use social media? And maybe
the reason that it wasn't done is because
it's actually not so simple because if we
think about social media there are many different
things right and many experiences that you
have whether it's on Facebook or writing a
blog are indeed very complex. And so as much
as it's nice that you can be in the MRI scanner
and you see a little screen in front of you
we like to have experiments in the MRI that
are very simple they are very controlled.
And so it actually was a little bit hard to
get from this really rich complex experience
on your computer or your phone to something
that we can look at in the scanner and what
was really exciting to me when I was trying
to think about OK how do we do this? Where
did we start? Right around the time that I
was thinking about this question Instagram
started to become really popular with teens.
And the thing that's cool about Instagram
is it takes what previously was very complicated,
if you think about Facebook that you have
several feeds at the same time lots of text,
Instagram suddenly makes it very simple. So
you have a picture. You have a little bit
of information about that picture, maybe the
likes and the number of comments.
And so the question that my colleagues and
I decided to look at is say you're looking
at a picture on Instagram but you look at
this picture and it has maybe two or three
likes and then your peer looks at the same
picture and now they see it and it has fifty
likes. How is this little bit of information,
how is this number going to change the way
that you respond to the picture. Are you more
likely to like it if it's popular and how
is it going to change the way that you take
in information, is your brain response to
that picture actually going to change? And
we zeroed in on this idea of the like because
it's something that really is brand new, right?
So for a very long time we've been telling
each other how we feel about information.
If I appear in front of you and I'm telling
you a joke I get sort of an idea of your response
based on you're smiling or your laughter.
But now we have this really interesting new
context where I'm getting a number that's
associated with something that I've created
or something I put out into the world. And
so what we found is that this little number,
the number of likes on a photo, affected how
likely teens were to like the pictures. So
they were significantly more likely to click
like, I use the word like a lot when I talk
about this, they're significantly more likely
to click like on the picture if they believe
that many of their peers have also liked it.
So we get this peer influence is kind of happening
in a new way online. And then we also saw
that their brain response was changing that
when they looked at a picture that had a lot
of likes versus a few they showed more activation
in a number of different parts of the brain
parts of the brain that are involved in social
cognition and thinking about your world parts
of the brain that are involved in visual perception,
so even though they're seeing the same thing
that parts of the brain that process visual
information are becoming more active which
suggests maybe they're scanning it a little
more carefully, paying attention to it in
a different way. And then the really interesting
thing that we find is that parts of the brain
are involved in reward and reinforcement.
So getting a reward of responding to that
reward being motivated to do something in
the future. These parts of the brain were
becoming more active when they saw that a
picture had a lot of likes and especially
if they saw that their own picture had a lot
of likes as I'm sure you can imagine.
So you're basically saying likes sort of like
chocolate or sex or crack will activate our
dopamine reward system. And how is this new?
How is this different than what teenagers
have been doing subtlety for thousands or
millennia?. So so what's particularly new
about digitality if that's a word?
Yeah, I mean that's kind of an open question
to some extent it is something that has already
existed. Right? So the idea that peers are
being influenced is absolutely not something
that is new. The idea that peers are very
motivated by what or that adolescents are
very motivated by what their peers think is
certainly something that already was happening
for a long time. And so some of the questions
that we're really interested in exploring
because again this is something we don't know
a lot about, is is this something that is
really new? Or are we just seeing this kind
of recapitulation of what we already knew
about adolescence. There are some things that
make social media very different. One is that
now there these numbers associated with information.
So the experience that you get of seeing that
people are liking you is a little bit more
like a currency. Right now it's quantifiable.
And so that's kind of the big question is
this in any way changing the experience of
getting information from your peers?
And what's great about your experiment was
that it was an experiment you actually manipulated
a number of likes that the photos got. So
you basically control the popularity.
Yes.
Currency there. But the cost of doing an experiment
is that you're seeing something in your fMRI
or or any other measures in real time that
is perhaps a short lived effect.
Yes
Richard, as a child analyst and psychiatrist
you're seeing sort of more globally the longer
term effect of the accumulation of these kind
of dopamine surges and disappointments and
so forth and multitasking in what it's doing
to our memory and all those kind of things.
So are you seeing more ADHD, more social disorders,
more mutism. What are you seeing in your practice?
Well in fact I think what's really important
about these different forms of social of the
digital tools is that they are one of the
headlines in a way to be able to provide our
work is work oftentimes in terms of summarizing
what we have been finding out in the research.
And I think it's really important for everybody
to think about them as tools that are for
communication, for entertainment and for education.
And that just like other tools they have advantages
and disadvantages. And I I think that some
of the debate that has been around about some
of the negative aspects of digital media and
digital tools is that there's like some global
effect that is all in one direction. So there's
the debate about the positives there's the
debate about the negatives and what's really
true is that people are pretty variable and
that there are positives and negatives and
it does impact people in different fashions.
So that we do see that some persons,
in getting heavily involved with games do
end up having more difficulties with their
attention especially if they are engaged with
these activities at a young age. If they get
involved a lot of this activity is in fact
a dose response relationship, in some of the
studies there's an indication that if you're
involved with gaming for about an hour a day
it's going to enhance your attention. If it's
more than three hours a day then it starts
to deteriorate and it has an impact on lots
of other activities that require some attention.
The same thing can be true with social media.
It depends on how you interpret the information.
Persons that get involved, there's a lot of
concern about Facebook and seeing how wonderful
everybody else is and like how diminished
your life is in comparison. If people approach
it with an envious way of dealing with things
it does result in more anxiety and depression
for adolescents. Than if people just say well
this is interesting. And is not going to be
too concerned about where I where I stand.
So I think the headline I would like to present
is that we need to be careful we need gather
a lot more information to know about the positives,
negatives and also the impact it has on people
individually.
Just to push up on that one point you said.
So let's take the example of the kid who games
for more than three hours a day. How do we
know and let's say they exhibit signs of depression
or loneliness or inattention how do we know
that's not, the gaming is not the effect and
not the cause?
There's a there's a good number of longitudinal
studies. There clearly is an indication that
for example in clinical populations kids with
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder are
more prone to get involved with gaming. But
in terms of longitudinal studies looking at
kids at a one time point and a later time
point there is an indication that they get
more involved with problems with attention,
if you know after extensive amounts of use.
I'm also aware of another study maybe you
were involved in Florida where they they send
kids off to camp for like a little under a
week and one group they took away their media
and the other group they let them keep it
at the end, of course, the ones without the
media had a better time but they could also
actually perform better on measures of social
cognition, reading other people's emotions
and empathy et cetera. So you would that's
consistent with what you're seeing in the
clinic?
Well oftentimes yes. Now again there's also
benefits for some kids that are socially isolated.
For some kids that have a little bit of difficulty
with some of their social skills some aspects
of social media and some aspects of games
that involve some social interaction, especially
the multiplayer games, sometimes that's better.
That that sometimes results the kids sometimes
coming more out of their shell. And actually
establishing community across boundaries.
Especially when they have very particular
interests.
Yeah.
You know Wikken golfers of the northeast Baltimore
are...OK.
I think Jan you have a more positive headline
for us or you were kind of mixed? So we're
going to end with the positive.
As I was looking to everybody I tried to decide
if I should come down in a positive way.
You're our only hope.
Yes, Obi Wan. I'm going to, I'm going to start
with the positive side because we can always
go back to the negative side that's always
soeasy.
And I'm sure we will.
And I'm going to tell you why I want to start
with the positive side but let me start by
by saying my headline is. We live in an age
that is unprecedented as far as the educational
opportunities are concerned that our children
have now. Not just in this country but all
over the world based on things that are designed
in this country and all over the world. And
so I do not just mean that we have information
at our fingertips on the web. I also mean
that we have simulations in which you can
explore scenarios that you don't directly
have access to. We have games that can motivate
those who have decided to disengage from something
that they thought wasn't really of interest
to them. We have so many genres now of educational
environments available to us that teachers
nowadays are almost complaining about the
wealth of different information and they don't
know how to choose from that. That did not
used to be the case when I was in school.
I very clearly remember not ever having any
of those tools and some of the adults in the
room probably that resonates with you.
So we have not only this unprecedented time
of wealth of information and high quality
information coming directly from the source,
from NASA from from all the from all different
kind of organizations that have done the research
and are presenting the results. But we also
are entering an age of well, shall I say accountability.
But what I mean is that is an age where there's
a quantification in a positive sense of what
how we're actually doing. And so what we're
seeing is, there was first the quantified
self movement in terms of how you know how
many steps you took today which is exciting.
Or I know how many miles I ran or bike this
week, which is also exciting but we're starting
to see systems, adaptive learning engines
that come out that tell you what your memory
strength is about what you've learned. What
you're good at what you are not good at. And
so we we're entering this age where we get
feedback about our learning personalized,
not as a group which is easy right, but personalized
that open a number of opportunities that we're
only barely starting to understand.
And so I said I would give you an example.
I'm going to keep it short. We just finished
a study with Syrian refugees in Turkey. As
you know there's a huge crisis in Syria. Lots
of families millions had to leave their homes.
Turkey is one of the countries that took in
the most of of those refugees and they're
living in camps. So the opportunities to learn
would have been very very limited had it not
been for digital media. So we were asked to
help out and we designed a four week curriculum
where they studied for two hours a day five
days a week for four weeks. We taught them
how to code. We taught them how to learn Turkish,
because you cannot get into school if you
don't know the language. We added cognitive
skills training especially executive functions
training. And because there's a lot of hopelessness
and lack of positive outlook we added a game
that actually gives you full control over
your own environment. Some of you guys might
be playing it, Minecraft. And so. So we had
this curriculum that is largely based on entirely
based on digital media and largely on games.
And we saw after four weeks so many positive
indications of having a positive impact on
that that we're now seeing to to scale this
up. And so if one wants to look on the positive
side those are some of the examples that I
would want to give.
I mean I volunteer for a online only tuition
free university called University of the People
that's trying to reach the same underserved
populations. But you're also teaching at NYU
and you're teaching both digitally only and
in the classroom in the brick and mortar sense.
What are the take home headline lessons, if
someone was going to try to develop pedagogical
games online?
Yeah that's a that's a really loaded question.
Let me start by saying that I do not believe
that entire curriculum should be game based.
Recently we've used games for brain training.
Kind of a topic that is a little bit controversial
ever since the Luminosity got fined $52 million
for making false claims about how effective
they are. So we decided well let's look at
that as researchers right. We were interested
in that, executive functions as underlying
almost everything we do. Right now you're
using all of your executive functions. You're
inhibiting the desire to do something else.
Perhaps you're using your working memory.
Your the shifting function is when different
people talk and have different ideas then
you shift and that's cognitive flexibility
involved. So it's something that we do for
almost everything we do of thought and action
and emotion and it can be trained. That's
the good news.
It's also something that as students, children
who don't have parents who can spend a lot
of time with them because they're need to
work two or three jobs. They don't get the
opportunities to train the executive functions,
which is one reason why we see an achievement
gap in schools. So what if you had a game
that could train your executive functions
and was actually a fun game to play. And so
we built some of those. We're testing them.
What we're doing is design research so we
compare two different versions we say here.
You know we actually worked with 11 to or
12 to 15-16 year olds a lot. We give them
the games and they play two different versions.
One might be adaptive. One might not be. One
has different game characters than the other
etc.. And then we look at which one works
better. And in the end we see what the overall
outcome is on academic achievement. Does it
actually enhance your performance in school
etc. and if that's all the case then they're
all available for free on our website. You
can play them at your heart's desire and see
if that works for you.
That's I think it was too much positive. Now
we tried.
A few years ago there was a study at UCLA
that divided people into learning something
while they were multitasking. And the other
group of course, were directed to have their
full attention on on not on the task of learning,
of memorizing something. And not only did
the ones that gave their full attention of
course do better on recall and in learning
a task they actually encoded in their brain
differently. So they, the multi-taskers they
found that there's striatum was more activated
and it was encoded as procedural memory which
is like driving a car where it's a habit,
but you're not as conscious of it. And the
people have focused store the new knowledge
and the new skill as declarative memory and
the hippocampus and the benefit of declarative
memory is that it allows you to abstract from
the particular to the general. So if you want
to drive a car maybe you don't want to drive
a motorcycle or a plane but if you know how
to solve a proof of you know partial differential
equation you might be able to transfer that
to something else that has the same basic
logical framework.
So are we all, Lauren, I’m looking at you
you but anyone can jump in. I mean one of
the consequences of the enormous number of
hours that we have our devices with us and
are on them and particularly young people
are we increasingly becoming kind of rote
machines where we learn how to do things through
procedural memory and that doesn't sound really
great for the age of the coming bots where
we really need to think in a more abstract
level to justify our usefulness over a robot.
So what are you finding in your research?
What are the consequences of multitasking
or our continuous partial attention?
Yeah. I haven't studied multitasking in particular.
Most of the stuff I've looked at it's more
in the social domain as opposed to the cognitive,
although the really interesting thing about
smartphones is now you're multitasking with
social information as well. And with multitasking
it sort of does depend on the kind of multitasking.
So if you are task switching very rapidly
in certain cases, you're not actually able
to multitask what we think of as holding two
things in your mind. You're going back and
forth and so as you mentioned there are some
disadvantages to doing that. On the other
hand there are certain ways that if you're
multitasking during a video game, if you're
playing sort of an action video game where
you have a lot of information in the environment
and you have to keep track of that first person
shooter, for example, those are situations
where you might have someone over here and
over there and now you are multitasking in
the sense that your attention is focused in
multiple areas.
And the really interesting thing is that there's
some research that finds that those kind of
games do improve your ability to hold information
in your mind at once. And so when we say multitasking
it really depends on what we're talking about
because on the one hand you get people who
are gamers are actually better at one kind
of multitasking. On the other hand people
who tend to report that they do a lot of using
social media while they're doing homework
and that sort of thing that they often will
show lower performance on certain tasks. So
again it's this idea that it really depends
on how you define it, that there are these
benefits or detriments but it's not one thing
even with multitasking.
Interestingly when you survey, surveys were
done a couple of years ago and you ask high
school students, "when you multitask do you
think that your performance academically,
when you're sitting doing your homework is
degraded?” they'll say no no no!
Yeah.
I think, unless someone here knows more, it's
really only the first person shooter action
video games that is suggesting that you can
get good at that kind of multitasking. So
you're entirely right you have to think about
what do we mean by multitasking.
If you're playing….
Wait, are you saying that if I let my son
play first the first person shooter video
games then he'll be able to listen to music
and
No,then he’ll be able to..
Watch instagram while he's doing his homework?
I wouldn't count on it. Then he'll be able
to do the first person shooter games really
well. And we really don't know about transferability
to other domains. We know there's certain
kinds of activities that go together. If you
play the piano you need two hands and you
need your feet. OK, is that multitasking?
It is in the version because all you have
to do is look at someone learning to play
the piano to begin with. And you can't coordinate
both hands. I'll never forget when I was teaching
my son to drive, he said I'll look ahead and
you look in the mirrors for me because I can't
do both. And then eventually you'll learn
you have to coordinate those pieces.
There has been research that suggests there
are certain people, maybe two to five percent
of the population who are super taskers who
actually can do well in multitasking. But
the experiments that were done at Stanford
a number of years ago said the people who
say I'm really good at multitasking were probably
worse. In fact the data shed showed were worse
than the people so I'm sorry I can't keep
track of multiple things at the same time.
But there's one other point I'd like to make
if I could and that has to do with what is
it we mean by learning? And part of the question
about whether digital technologies are helping
us learn or not is that on the one hand digital
technologies are really good for finding facts.
Or for finding pieces of information which
may be collections of facts. And we use the
technologies for getting those little pieces.
However if we don't have a context that says
there is more to learning than this…there's
is something we want to call knowledge. There's
something that's called two years from now.
How did you integrate those pieces that you
learned? Then I think we're missing out an
important part of what learning should be
about.
The same thing I think goes for adaptive learning
for certain subjects can be absolutely superb
and far better than the vast majority of teachers
most of us have had. On the other hand one
of the problems or one of the challenges of
adaptive learning is if we say this could
work in any discipline, you then have to say
for doing philosophy how do you make that
adaptive for a learning tool. And are those
the things that are most important to learn
in philosophy or is that a way of thinking
about problems? And I don't know that we know
how to code that into smaller pieces and if
you can figure it out please help.
I'm not sure that's something that I can figure
out this moment but I can say that the term
‘adaptive learning’ evokes certain people
and certain ideas in certain people and from
just just listening to how you describe it
I can imagine how you would think about it
and I imagine everybody else here has a different
opportunity, a different experience and what
adaptive might have meant. And that's the
problem with adaptivity and personalization
as this other buzzword that we're using right
now personalized learning, adaptive learning,
individualized learning. And nobody really
knows what the differences are, or better
yet everybody has their own definition but
uses those words interchangeably.
So adaptivity the way I would describe it
means that any learner at any time gets what
that learner needs to succeed. Right? And
if that is applied to philosophy that would
mean entirely different things than if I learn
math or language. Right but we don't know
how to do that yet, right? So we have and
I developed just to explain it to myself,
I developed this taxonomy which is in a new
kind of categories of how one could do adaptive
learning. And when you look at that entire
taxonomy there are maybe thirty different
ways of doing that alone on the cognitive
domain but then we have the affective of domain.
We have a social, cultural domain. We have
have motivational domains of where where we
could adapt that way. Right. And so when you
look at that and when you look at the existing
adaptive systems when we're talking about
intelligent tutoring systems and other systems
that kind of try to guess, to predict what
you need and mostly that means you just solve
this problem, this math equation. You're not
ready to solve this math equation. It's a
little harder. Right. That would never work
in philosophy but that's just such a small
part of what adaptivity could mean. But as
as researchers, as learning scientists we're
just in the beginning of understanding that.
Or understanding how to build it. We understand
what we would love to happen but not how to
do it.
Also if I may, I think we’re in the process
also understanding what it does mean to be
multitasking because you know the definition
is probably not clear enough. What's often
described as multitasking is really switching
from one activity to another. There are some
benefits for multitasking that have been documented
in work with kids, in other persons for example.
A colleague of mine did some work a good number
of years ago on the idea of helping kids with
attention problems and trying to see what
happens if they listened to music as they're
doing their work. If they select the music,
they actually improve their productivity.
It seems that kind of the brain is multitasking.
There’s one part that's kind of attending
to the music sort of like activating the brain
and making it like .....
Keeping it occupied? that part occupied?
Kind of keeping it occupied, more like an
idling in the car. The car is ready to move
up and to advance when they present to a problem.
And the same thing has been fun with adults
when they're involved with doodling and listening
to lectures
That's the fidget spinner right?
Well it is.
The idea is like you're doing something you're
taking up part of that energy.
Yeah, but like doodling does results in people
paying better attention to lectures that are
being presented. So I think that to be really
careful of these definitions because we can't
get overly broad in that regard and get confused.
So you're in the business of actually giving
best practices to to families the parents
of how to manage this brave new world that's
exploding upon us. So what are some of the
points to what are some of the basic things
that given all this kind of context specificity
on the one hand, on the other hand what do
you tell us to do with our kids?
Well I think one thing that's really important
is to be a bit more very conscious of what
we are talking about to be really tuned into
it and not. I think one thing that has happened
is that we think that this technology is not
understandable. And that it's like so brand
new that it can't be put into a context and
perhaps I'm being too simplistic and maybe
that's the way my mind works. But I do think
that it's really helpful for people to say,
well many of these instruments are a means
of communication. You know so what do you
think about the role of communication in your
children's lives and what kind of communication
do you want them to have? There's they're
tools for education. What kind of education
what kind of content do you want to have your
kids learn about and what what methods, what
things you want to be involved with in terms
of leisure? And I like to be able to suggest
to parents that they think about you know,
for example, with education you can use digital
resources to be able to learn how to be you
know some really problematic issues. You can
you can learn to be a really good anorexic.
You can learn to be a good bomb maker. You
can also do all the different kinds of fascinating
things have been presented here already.
With communication you can get really good
at being a bully. You can also get really
good at being able to communicate to people
in Alaska and you know in Africa and many
other communities that you can really make
a good set of connections. And with leisure
time you can spend you know most of your time
on junk and things that are not going to be
very, very useful or you could do it on some
things that are fulfilling and a little bit
of junk. And so I think when parents do that
and think about these things as similar to
what they were presented as kids. And I think
that helps kind of like put a context into
that's really very useful.
How how is a parent to control all of this?
I mean, Dana Boyd at Microsoft Research argues
that actually all of the stuff like the specific
teen talk that parents can't decode on social
media sites and so forth, is all response
to the fact that we over program and over
control our kids today. Not an effect but
actually, sorry not actually cause but the
effect of what we're doing already in trying
to kind of control their worlds. I mean I'm
I'm I'm not only de-friended from my son's
Facebook I'm blocked. So what am I to do it?
I think the thing is, you know kids and adolescents
have always found some way to keep things
secret. The question is like how secret and
how problematic. You know I work in a clinical
setting. You don't want to be the parent of,
and this is a number of years ago when things
were just starting, to find out that your
twelve year old daughter has gotten really
obsessed with something and really concerned
showing a lot of signs of anxiety because
what has happened is she met somebody at camp.
The boy's been sexting with her and that she's
like now preoccupied and she doesn't know
how to stop it. And you don't want to be the
parent that finds out that when you go to
Verizon and find out, OK here's the series
of texts that has been going on for months.
You don't want to be the parent that finds
out that your teenage son, and these these
are cases, has been involved with staying
up and chatting and texting into, you know,
five in the morning with a girl who's suicidal.
You want to be able to have some sense of
what is going on. You don't even know each
and every detail you get to know the trends.
That sounds good but how does one effect that?
Well I think what you do is you do kind of
like recognize that these again are tools
you know like the example I gave in my talks
is that you know we have chainsaws. Chainsaws
are very useful. They're very helpful. They
help us do a lot of different things. But
then you have the Texas Chainsaw Massacre,
can be used in a different way. Not to just
think about it as being something that you
can't step into. Not to think that like OK
every kid, and I've had some situations where
people were saying eight year olds having
an inalienable right to privacy. Well really?
Did you grow up that way? Did your parents
raise you that way? I mean we've been parenting
for a long time. And I think we have to try
to be logical and reasonable to say, well
I do need to know a little bit of the trend.
I do need to know what's going on. I do need
to be tuned in enough to be aware of what
you're doing.
And the technology tools that we sometimes
feel are so overwhelming that we don't even
want to start to understand what our children
are doing can also be used to help with that.
Right? So I have my favorite app on my phone
is the one that lets me turn off the Wi-Fi
and the Wi-Fi in our house is tightly controlled
because both of my kids would be on at all
times if I didn't. And for a while we collected
the devices and then they got really smart
and they were hiding them. So now you can
hide your iPod as much as you want but the
Wifi is off or it's on for certain hours.
And they have phones with 4G?
Well so there's that right. So you need to
look at. You need to look at all the different
ways of how your children manage to get the
information that they want to get. But what
I'm saying is that. That, and I think that's
Richard's point, that that has always been
the case. We just have to not give up or give
in to say, well technology it's just so hard
to understand what these kids do nowadays
so we just let them do anything.
And what's interesting is my fourteen year
old, and I probably shouldn't mention his
name the poor guy, but he will tell me about
other kids in his class that have far more
control over their digital life than he does.
And he says it half admiring and half kind
of you know understanding why he does not
get that from us. He's also the one who asked
me, Dad you do research on games for learning
why don't we have an Xbox or a PS4 in our
house? And you know it's the same reason.
The other reason is that my office is right
across the street so you can do that. But
you know we need to take charge and is a new
digital literacy on the part of the parents
involved and a new digital literacy on the
part of the children involved that we need
to teach them about because the kind of things
that they're posting before they have found
out what can happen or can the hair raising
sometimes and so Don't let them.
I'm not going to reveal my own, because this
is going to be archived on the web, don't
want to reveal my secret ways to adapt to
this. I mean your kids are 11 and 14. So I
want to interview you again in four years
and see if you can do that. Mine are 17 and
19. But and yes everybody is learning about
what you should or should not text or post,
you know understanding that you're on a public
stage part of part of the problem of social
media or that of the problem. But is it the
ratio of what sociologist Erving often called
front stage and back stage, where intimate
private things were done backstage and I think
that created intimacy by letting people into
your secrets. And front stage was how you
behave here on front stage. But is that being
eroded. Laura like is it is when you're a
blur. Are people still managing to maintain
front and backstage on social media?
I mean I think that. It is with everything
kind of dependence. I can think of examples
of teenagers actually using social media in
a way that they divide that into a front stage
and back stage. So even just thinking about
the different social media that teens use.
What's been really interesting to me, in the
I haven't been doing research for all that
long but in the time that I've been doing
it seeing how the tools are change and seeing
what is popular. So when I started doing my
work on Instagram it was before too many teens
were using it. By the time I was finished
it was very popular and teenagers had Facebook
but they are boring and they didn't really
use them and since then in talking to adolescents
they describe it as a little bit more like
Linkedin where I think at some point there
is this message that colleges are going to
look at your Facebook and so teens started
thinking about it as Oh yes. Well a college
is going to look at my Facebook so it has
to look very nice and you know they're thinking
of it is this a way that they present themselves
to the world
Whereas something like Instagram which nowadays
many many teens have Instagram is on private
so it's not something that most of the world
can see. Now it doesn't mean that there's
no possibility that something they post could
ever get out there. But I think it's definitely
true that adolescents are very aware of one.
Not always but but they do often have an awareness
of when something is private or not when something
is again ephemeral or not. It was really fascinating
to me when Snapchat became so popular because
for a long time what we talked about is the
idea that social media, the Internet is there
is always available and that in the case of
cyberbullying for example that you go home
and you still see this horrible message that
somebody posted. And so the things that we
worried a lot about this idea that information
didn't go away now was kind of being flipped
on its head. And I think that's why Snapchat
was so exciting for teens.
And you see what's really funny is on Snapchat
became popular I think a lot of parents worried
that it would be used for sexting. Right?
Because it's you take a picture or video and
then it disappears and so you can immediately
think of what that may be used for and instead
what teenagers use it for was to take really
stupid pictures of their faces and send them
to each other. And so it's this idea that
it's more casual and it's not something that
has to look very beautiful and perfect. And
now we're also looking face to face on these
tools. So you mentioned the study by my colleague
Yalda Uhls also looking at when kids have
their devices basically taken away and they
went to camp for a week and then at the end
of that they showed they were better able
to read facial expressions and understand
prosody and voices. That's how he was done,
I think maybe five or six years ago now and
I really wonder if he was done again now if
the same facts would be found? Because we've
moved from a very text based hall to tools
where they're very audiovisual in nature they're
getting a little far afield of your question.
But I think privacy you should get back to
that is something that adolescents really
do think about and they navigate or at least
they may become more interested in tools because
of the affordances as related to privacy.
So I don't think it's true that that's disappeared.
I think it's just it looks a little different
now.
One of the questions that's been raised a
couple of times is is it different in social
media then it, whatever it is right now in
the rest of the world. And at this point I'll
put my linguists hat on and say one of the
things we know about learning to use language,
particularly by the time you get to be a teenager
and somewhat younger for many of those skills
is, you are really good at knowing what you
say to whom when. And you know there are certain
kinds of things you will say to your parents
that you will not say to your friends and
vice versa, that you will say to some friends
but not other friends. There has been studies
done going to this front stage back stage
behavior issue. There are people who will
say Are you certain what used to be emoticons
and now it's probably emojis or gifs, and
I’ll use certain events with some people
but I'll use others with other people. So
we know that by the time you were 10, 11 and
definitely by the time you're 14 or 15 you
have a lot of these skills of shifting registers
as it's called, and what you say and how you
say it to whom. So this question of being
able to control your own behavior if you choose
to. Is something you already have another
skill for and you're just translating it whether
it's with words or whether it's visual images
that work the same way.
But there's just one other point that I wanted
to make that comes to what I'll call the technological
determinism argument. It's very easy to think
this new technology is here. It's going to
take us over and we have to some extent set
that with a lot of digital media. What can
I do? It's going to happen in the realm that
I live in, oh digital texts are going to come
you know print is over or this what can I
do as a parent? I have no choice.
Well of course you have choices. And does
that mean there will be some disagreements
they'll be disagreements. But there were disagreements
about driving cars there were disagreements
about alcohol. There were disagreements about
your hairstyle. There were disagreements about
when you get a phone. There were disagreements
about are you allowed to drink. I mean these
have been going on going on for a long time.
The difference here is now there's this device
you can carry in your hand and you can do
a lot more things, you hope, in private than
you could before. But the issues haven't changed
and the responsibilities that we have whether
we're parents or teachers haven't changed.
It's tough to try to figure out what works
well with these media what can they do really
well better than we could do let's say in
face to face conversation. What is it that
they can be very dangerous about and we need
to map this, and that's something that we
talk about occasionally but we haven't really
seriously tried to come to grips with.
And I would argue that there's another thing
that has changed and we call that design thinking.
So it used to be that the media we had and
the information we had were kind of a given
that were very hard to change, before the
printing press probably more than after. But
nowadays if you think that that Snapchat tool
or the Facebook or the other tools that you're
using are not the ones you want to use you
actually are empowered to learn how to program
and do your own. And so I tell my children
or student a lot about that, when you walk
through the world with a designers perspective
you look around, so those monitors are placed
very nicely but those lights you know maybe
you should shift them over a little bit. Or
this app doesn't work for me. This obviously
was designed by a white guy sitting in a garage
in Silicon Valley and that's not me., impersonate
someone else, that I have very different needs
right. And then then you don't have to say
well there's nothing there for me. What you
can do is you can learn how to program. We
now in New York City start in high school
to do that. CS for all, for better or worse.
I mean there are arguments for or against
but the design thinking argument would be
we give you the tools to change the world
around you start a new company. We have incubators
here all over town and make it a not for profit
if that's what you believe in. But but think
about the world as something that can be changed
and media in the world can be changed. And
to me that is super exciting to come back
to the positive side a little bit. That's
super exciting because that didn't used to
be the case.
Given the perhaps the positive side, didn't
Socrates complain about writing down text
because you thought that that would destroy
the skill with memorization? I mean how do
you respond to that and that this is just
that complaint over and over again in terms
of your concerns about deep reading for example?
I mean there is evidence you know there was
a article on the cover of Atlantic that was
one of the most read called is Google making
a stupid? And there was experimental evidence
that if you use Google would they allow people
to use Google earlier and prime them that
way, they did worse in terms of they were
lazier in terms of remembering facts later
on
Right OK
So but obviously there must be some upside.
There's you know the world's information or
fingertips, so what's different for humanities
and for deep reading and writing?
Alright, you we wanted me to start with Socrates.
I'm happy to begin there. You have to remember
it was an oral culture. It was an oral culture
in and out of Greece. It was an oral culture
in Rome, there was a lot of writing in Rome
anybody learn Latin? So there's a lot of writing
but it was an oral culture with an oral culture.
And it used to be called England now the UK,
up through really Shakespeare's time. Shakespeare's
plays, although they're written down for the
rescript so that people could learn their
parts, they were meant to be performed. And
only when after Shakespeare's death and some
of the members of his company put them together
in the so-called First Folio around 1623 I
think was it said ‘read them now!’ OK
because it was an oral culture. OK so when
somebody says are memories going to go. I
mean but this was a time when certain people
would know the Iliad they would know the Odyssey
by heart. Thank you. OK. We live in a different
time writing really seriously began for bureaucracies,
for keeping track of records. Literature is
a Johnny-come-lately for writing philosophy
depending upon how you want to think about
it because Socrates didn't write the stuff
down, Plato did.
By writing we were able to sit and reflect
on what was written. And a lot of things have
been I think appropriately argued that says
one of the benefits of writing is you can
come back to it you can contemplate it you
might stand up and walk around for a while
and then you come back to it. The thing about
digital technologies is it doesn't encourage
our coming back.
Well, so here's a question so if Socrates
was kind of looking ahead at the way the world
changed he’d be very upset that there's
nobody who's out there in the world who has
memorized yet. Whereas we go about our lives
and nobody is particularly concerned about.
Would he be I don't know.
Well, I don’t know, but say that if he was
upset about the idea that there was some sort
of degradation of mental faculties based surprisingly
down or something I think about with memory.
I think about with memory. What I was talking
about. Can you think through a problem. Let's
remember he's in the really early days of
Greek philosophy.
So I guess what I'm saying is the way that
I've always interpreted that quote isn't there
sort of a value judgment on it right? that
he's not happy about the way that things are
going. So to speak and he you might be valuing
different things in an oral culture than we
would value now so I guess the question that
I'm getting at is, is it possible that we
won't be having these conversations 20 years
from now because what we value may not be
your ability to answer questions about that
you've read but it may be your ability to
look information up and to know where to find
it. I mean I'm being a little bit provocative
on purpose, yeah,
You're hitting it right on your head.
What I think is, it's challenging today is
we are tending to let our technologies reshape
what we think learning, writ large should
be about. And there are many people who say
if you can learn to do a good search that's
much more important than what you have in
your head. I think that the study that you
just mentioned that says if you done a Google
search on topic X and then it ask you what
you know about topic y as opposed to another
group of people who have not done a good Google
search on topic X but I ask you about topic
y the people who have done a search on Google
for X will tell you they know more about topic
why. Not having done any search than the people
who didn't have that I know how to do search
therefore I must know all the substance that's
in the search. So I think what we're doing
is defining ourselves down in a very negative
sense. We don't have to do this. We're doing
it by default because the easiest thing to
do with the Internet is do a search and feel
that you know something.
We know that when students write papers they
will cite their sources. The first page in
the book. Some will cite the first three pages
something from the first three pages almost
nobody cites anything later in the book. OK.
So this is even with print books. Digitally
you go and whether my students do and I ask
them the question for an online discussion?
They say Ah. Where in the article is that
topic that you asked us to talk about? And
they read the line above and the line below
and they talk about it and they say done!
I just wanted to push push slightly back on
one thing which is as a scientist I would
say if I want someone to read the full article,
I give them an assessment or a task that requires
reading the whole article right? So if I make
it meaningful to someone when you read this
article you can solve this problem. They read
your article or they can't solve the problem.
So I think we should as faculty as professors
as teachers take on the challenge to say how
can we make what we think of as a test of
an assessment of a measure for how much we
learn how can we make that more meaningful?
And I think a lot of the, they only you read
the line above the line below is that people
are actually very smart in understanding how
that question needs to be answered. And we
learn that from games.
You would think that people play games the
way we design them and then you're shocked
to hear that people game the game. If you
if you design a game that has too many rewards
in it people will find the way to get those
rewards. If you design the game with very
few rewards where you might get the occasional
star or so but you get actually when you do
the task in the game well whatever it might
be flinging birds at pigs are so, right? If
you do that well you actually get something
that matters to you maybe just in the context
of the game but something that is that is
in that moment personally relevant and meaningful
to you. Then you'll expend the energy. I you
just get the sense that if I do this one thing
right on the test and then I can move on then
we don't, right. And so so the challenge is
that but I think the point is so well-taken
that technology is shaping us and that is
disempowering in a way that we shouldn't let
it right. And so we're struggling with that
because there's so much of it and strange
on that.
My favorite book came out a long time ago
on this issue is Neil Postman's “Technopoly,”
wonderful book a wonderful read. Probably
the first chapter that people will ever read.
But I still really enjoyed it. And and one
of the simplest examples that he gave and
it took make everybody pause as we used to
sit down at family dinner and we would have
dinner, right? And nobody would knock at somebody's
house to come and interrupted dinner. But
when the phone rings everybody jumps up, we
still have to go and pick up the phone and
say there are things that intrude in what
used to be family life or life in general
that we really have to ask ourselves is that
worth giving up? Or. Or is that really something
that we want to retain? And obviously opinions
will vary on what we can and shouldn't give
up. But people walk into traffic to pedestrian
traffic deaths up by 10 percent or so on.
And people attribute that to people just staring
at their phones, And if just walk around and
you'll see a lot of examples of that people
will sit in restaurants across from each other
both on their phones and deeply engaged in
whatever they're doing just not with each
other. And so where do we want to push back
as a culture as a society as parents and say
when, we still can, and say look this is this
is something that we don't want to have. Right?
And it's very very hard but we can't give
up. We have to we have to keep fighting the
good fight.
I think that debates and then these discussions
I think are we we're at a phase where we are
recognizing that these are important and powerful
tools but I also think that those debates
and these concerns are letting us become sort
of like catching up with technology. And I
think if we look at history that is the way
that it goes. And then when something new
is brought out there is a little bit of time
and there is a gap between like really learning
how to use it well and effectively. And one
part I'd like to also bring out is not only
that working in teaching kids about using
things effectively well and having them be
cautious. I do think, from the perspective
of parents and adults we have to do the same.
Because there is a good amount of indication
that when adults are not using these materials
appropriately, indirectly they're also harming
their kids. There's a there's a fair amount
of studies that are being looked at right
now with regard to parents use of phones and
in connection with connecting with their infant
kids and kind of like giving their kids these
these tools too early so they don't get advantages.
On that note I want to ask one last question
Richard, before we go to the audience, which
is that the American Society of pediatricians
recently revised their regulations used to
be zero digital media for those under two
years of age and now they've relaxed that,
is that the right policy?
I think so I think it's well founded in reason.
All the concern had been based upon work that
had been done that found that kids at this
early age would inhibit their attention and
their capacity to be able to pay attention.
But more subsequent studies indicated that,
well it's so it's within reason it's fine.
I think that is what is happening. We're coming
to reasonable understanding how to use things
and I think that that's what happened with
the Academy of Pediatrics. And I also suspect
that part of what happened because many of
the people involved as they got younger cohort
started to say well this really doesn't seem
like it could actually happen. So what what
what what can really be reasonable ways?
And they're concerned that kids who don't
learn these technologies at that age are really
behind their peers?
Exactly. Exactly right. There'll be a digital
divide which would be inappropriate as well.
So we have 10 minutes for questions from the
audience. Also in the back there.
This is more about adults and social media
I suppose. But, I asked my dad thus a long
time ago, whether, because he had just gotten
on to Facebook and was talking to people he
hadn’t talked to in twenty years, they both
immigrated ages ago. And I asked whether it
was better to forget about all those friends,
you had met twenty years ago and let them
fade out of your memory like you would before
social media. Or is better to check in, you
know this shallow bits of lives without being
involved with them. Because ultimately which
is more painful? Which is sadder and he never
really responded an answer to that. So I always
wondered from Neuroscience perspective what
works? Is it better to a social, shallow understanding
of other people's lives or just let them fade
away?
So I think the question you are asking. You're
talking about a value judgment right? Is it
better or is it worse. And this comes up again
and again is there is never going to be this
universal idea of what is better or worse
if you're talking about emotions or your particular
experience that you have there maybe people
for which having those connections long term
being able to maintain them having, though
it may be shallow continue in connection with
someone is better or worse. I think there's
this hope that we have that we can look in
the brain and suddenly become objective. Right?
Is that because it's science because it's
something that's physical or biological we
can use all these words and say all right
now we're getting from this kind of touchy
feely psychology stuff where it's just whatever
you think you are. Now we're going to look
in the brain and unfortunately that or maybe
fortunately, I don't know if it's unfortunate
but it's just not how the brain works I mean
the one thing I will say that's really incredible
about our brains is that they're very good
at adapting to all sorts of different situations
and, in fact, there are a lot of developmental
cognitive scientists and I'm one of them who
think that there's something really special
about the adolescent period that our brain
is very sensitive to our social sphere because
we're learning about our particular culture.
And so something that's going to be valued
very highly in my culture the number of friends
that I have. The way that I interact with
people may be very different from what is
valued in another culture. And it's this wonderful
thing that our brains allow us to figure that
out. It can be very tough when as you age
your culture starts to change and the way
that you grew up is now very different. But
all of that is to say that the brain is never
going to tell you whether it's better or worse.
And in fact for these questions sometimes
it's better to ask yourself or to ask somebody
else sometimes. What we think of as being
more touchy feely is actually going to have
more of a direct effect on our outcomes and
how to guide our behavior a little better.
Time for one last question.
My question is you talk about with a lot,
a of conversations has been rear view kind
of taking this to this point but if you just
roll over what would be the headline ten years
from now? What’s the impact on learning
and how we behave? One last point, they are
showing or some study is showing that the
psychological profile of 16 year old the 25
year old is almost actually the same. That's
one of the changes, right. So going forward
what was the headline? If you take your conversation
for roll it forward a for a few years. What's
the impact on us and how things can change.
From a learning perspective?
I’ll take a first shot, I'd rather not go
ten years because I don't know what I could
see but five years perhaps and I'll start
with the example of digital versus print.
It was widely predicted around 2011, 2012
that print really was going to fade. And what
has happened instead is we've really reached
what's known as a both-and world. There are
certain things that we do digitally all the
time the certain things that we are doing
a lot in print and that's not just one person
or another person it's independent bookstores
are coming back and if you look at sales figures
and growth levels for digital books versus
print books, print books has a higher growth
rate than digital does. And audio is way higher
than both of them. I think the same thing
is going to happen and maybe it's because
of the settling in period for are coming to
grips with, we get to control what we do with
the devices. We get to control what the devices
are. We get to make our own decisions. I think
we're going to get tired of being shallow.
We know that people who spend a lot of time
on Facebook often either feel depressed because
everybody looked better than they did or so
they think or what came from those three hours?
Zilch. And at some point you know our education
patterns change or social patterns change.
And I think at least within five years we're
going to see more of a balance and more a
feeling that we're in control of what we're
doing and we'll have a range of choices and
feel that we have the right to make those
choices.
I love that that as an answer. But I think
in five years we will have had two more waves
of new technologies that all promise to solve
all of our right. And that then only ended
up adding to what we have available at our
fingertips that in our arsenal is just if
you want. now have to choose which way of
teaching and learning is the best way for
me for particular subject for particular context
etc. so I am unfortunate as much love your
vision more than mine I think we are going
to be faced with this ever changing technological
world we live in. Where where new interventions
and inventions will come out that will challenge
us. And so we need to be up for the tasks
we need to to be ready for that and how to
do that would be probably a topic for another
panel.
I think it's important also to say that technology
is not its own realm sui generis or isolated
from other changes going on in society whether
that's changing age structures and in society
as we age because of low fertility rate or
rising economic inequality the changing nature
of work and prolonged adolescence which is
symbolized by Obamacare where kids can stay
on their their parents health insurance till
25 or 26. So we can't talk about the future.
It's hard enough to read and present. It's
almost impossible to talk about the future
at all. Certainly in isolation from from other
forces that are at work and we can't predict.
So thank you to everyone for attending this
evening. Thank you again everybody.